[Penicillin and Venereal Disease]
[Presented by the U. S. Public Health Service in cooperation with State and Local Health Departments]
[This is a portion of the motion picture Penicillin
in Medicine and Surgery produced by
Grant, Flory & Williams and distributed by E. R. Squibb & Sons]
[ Narrator: ] The United States Public Health
Service has had a major role in determining
the value of penicillin in the treatment of
venereal disease. Much of this work has been
done under the direction of Dr. J.R. Heller,
Jr.
[ Dr. J.R. Heller: ] More than 200,000 new
infections of syphilis are acquired in this
country each year. All are actually or potentially
highly infectious.
If these patients could be found and treated
before they have a chance to spread their
infections, there would soon be a marked reduction of syphilis.
Increased alertness and diagnosis is important
as a first step in bringing this about.
Early diagnosis not only aids in reducing syphilis,
but also is important in improving the
outlook for cure of the individual patient.
[ Narrator: ] One or more of these cases, too
often unnoticed or unlooked for, may be present
in the physician's waiting room. Physicians
should examine the genitalia, the skin, and
the mucosa for lesions of early syphilis.
They should employ both darkfield microscopic
examinations and blood serologic tests. Look
for such symptoms as early penile lesions,
the lip chancre, and the noticeable gumma.
Other manifestations are the sore throat,
any mucosa lesions which do not heal in ten
days, any unexplained loss of hair...
general malaise, loss of weight, fever, or
macular and maculopapular and group follicular eruptions.
The clinician may occasionally be surprised
to find among his patients long-neglected
cases. such as this example of advanced syphilis.
The early latent stage often passes unrecognized.
There are probably scores of latent syphilis
cases passing through your office each year.
Blood and spinal fluid tests are the principle
diagnostic procedures available in the early
latent stage of syphilis.
This applies also to the late latent stage
with an increased probability of positive
spinal fluid findings. For example, the colloidal
gold test for paresis appears in this manner.
And is usually indicated by this type of curve.
[Chart reading Spinal Fluid Dilutions in .4% Sodium Chloride Controls is shown,]
While the test for a [?] reaction responds
in this manner.
Let us look at some typical latent manifestations
of syphilis.
Penile lesion
Aneurysm.
Charcot's joint.
Ocular nerve palsy and optic atrophy.
Syphilis of the central nervous system.
Paresis or tabes.
On the basis of present evidence, penicillin
appears to have great value in the treatment
of syphilis in virtually all stages and manifestations.
This lesion, which we saw earlier, has been
treated with penicillin. Treatment was on
a schedule of forty thousand units every three hours, which will total
two million four hundred thousand units in seven and one half days.
The healing of this lesion was accompanied
by a serologic reversal which occurred
over a five-week period. We cannot always expect
such ideal results, however.
The more obstinate cases may require prolonged therapy and attention.
Serologic reversal may require many weeks or months, and in some
rare cases, even clinical symptoms may recur.
No final statement can be made at this time
regarding the place penicillin will eventually
occupy in the treatment of syphilis.
Developments are occurring are so rapidly
that it is not feasible to recommend here
precise dosages and methods of administration,
but it is important to keep abreast of progress
in the field.
Your professional societies and journals,
your health departments, and the United States
Public Health Service are all reliable sources
of information.
Against gonorrhea, the advent of penicillin
presents a strong and efficient weapon. Here
we can be more definite in our suggestions.
Under penicillin therapy, the gonorrhea patient
is completely ambulatory.
Toxic reactions are almost unknown. Discomfort and pain are slight.
Fortunately the gonococcus is highly susceptible
to penicillin, and control is apparent almost
at once.
The patient from whom this specimen was taken
received four intramuscular doses of 50,000
units of penicillin in aqueous solution at
three-hour intervals. Total:  200,000 units.
Within 24 hours, the smear should be negative.
Complications such as epididymitis, arthritis,
and endocarditis require larger and prolonged
dosage.
As an alternative procedure, a single dose
of 300,000 units of penicillin in oil and
wax has proved effective in gonorrhea with
a minimum of inconvenience to the patient.
[Warning: The maximum penicillin dosage for gonorrhea may inhibit the normal development
of clinical and serologic symptoms of a concomitant
syphilis infection.]
[A blood specimen for serologic testing should
be taken before therapy is begun.]
[Each gonorrhea patient should be strongly
urged to report for serologic and other tests
for syphilis at suitable intervals for three to
six months after completing the treatment for gonorrhea.]
[ Dr. John R. Heller, Jr.: ] Whatever the
future may hold for penicillin therapy, we
physicians already have in our hands weapons,
which with proper medical usage should enable
us to reduce materially the amount of venereal
disease in the United States.
[The End]